music plays an important role in our
lives it can help us relax concentrate
or hit pumped for a workout and if this
song makes you happy well it's because
it's affecting your brain chemistry so
why do we find music so enjoyable
researchers from McGill University in
Montreal found that dopamine releases
during moments of enjoyment while
listening to music it's what gives us
the chills the same chemical reaction as
when you fall in love basically
listening to music is amazing and your
brain loves it music also distracts your
brain from registering the body's
fatigue it increases endurance while
improving the heart and muscles giving
music both a psychological and
physiological impact on the body think
about that next time you're at the gym
and forget your headphones and did you
know that playing a musical instrument
can make you smarter and more of an
annoying neighbor sorry Charlie
believe it or not children with at least
three years of musical training
performed better during testing for
nonverbal reasoning fine motor skills
auditory discrimination and vocabulary
than those who did not we generally
don't realize how a simple song can
affect our brains and bodies
nevertheless music has a measurably
significant effect on human beings
influencing the way we dance exercise
and think so how is music affected your
life
Wow